To generate a web application, you can use the web
app factory. Simply putting in some details of what you
want to build here for this demo we will implement
Graphic. Implements a graphing
calculator. Save your idea. Make sure that you have
some models selected. We're going to be using Gemini 3
Flash preview for this demo. You do have to have
an image model selected even if you aren't using it
It doesn't have to be actually an image model. You
just have to select something. And then we go to
pipeline and build web app. This is the only step
in this pipeline, but this step is quite involved
It starts by generating Project plan of tasks and
then executes them appropriately, keeping in mind all of their
dependencies, as you will see in a moment. Here
we see the project plan with 5 different tasks. It's
currently executing the first task. As it proceeds through
the plan, the graph will update. And
we just have to wait until the project is implemented
Of course, these nodes are not displaying correctly, but we
can view the tasks themselves here. So
here it creates the foundational documents for the projects, influences
HTML structure, visual style. Now it's implementing
the core logic. And
once it is complete, the web app UI will update
The implementation stuff is done and we can see the
read me in the project route. At this point we
can download the zip if you want. Also notable is
that this application has Git support integrated into it. If
you know what Git is, it's a version if you
don't know what Git is, it is a version control
system that essentially allows you to. Version
control files. I'm
not sure what that error was about, but. It did
save the files to get. Now
that the implementation is done, we can also launch the
app. And here we see we are plotting
sin of x. What happens if we say sin of
x plus 10 of X? Here we go. That looks
about right. Or what about divide instead of times? What
about times? Oh, power
that looks interesting. Anyway, it seems to work, but you
know what? It's too bright. Let's
ask for some changes. Update. We can update our web
app using the updater, you know, we can say. Implement
a dark. A theme. Save
our notes and run the update. This will update our
project with our requested updates. This can also be useful
if you see bugs or want a new feature or
really any change. The update is done. Let's go look
at our gaffing calculator, refresh it, and oh. We've got
a theme button and it works. So, that's how to
use the web app factory to generate your own applications
We can also click usage and we can see that
this entire project demo cost 11 cents so far. I
hope you find this useful.